Let's look at the solution to our
SMT and cache relationship quiz.
We have three programs.
Program A has a working set
that doesn't fit in the cache.
That means that program A will
have a lot of cache misses no
matter what we do.
Program B alone would fit in the cache.
Program C alone would fit in the cache.
Programs B and C would fit in the cache,
but if we run all three together,
then the total working set size is
15KB which doesn't fit in the cache,
so all of them get poor cache behavior.
So really we should not be
running all three together.
We should not be running A and
B together, because
then C gets to run alone so
we don't benefit from SMT and
B runs with A, so
B also has a lot of cache misses.
We should run A and then B and C.
That way,
A which has to get poor cache behavior,
gets poor cache behavior alone.
But B and C benefit from SMT and
fit in the cache, so
they still get good cache behavior.
So we should do this.
Just like we shouldn't run B with A,
we shouldn't run C with A, and
then running A and then B and
then C is not benefiting from SMT
although B and C would fit in the cache.
So that's why this is
the only correct answer.